meist weht der wind kräftig über das
kleine königreich
beste bedingungen also um rotoren in den
wind zu stimmen
1991 waren die dänen die ersten die
anlagen auf dem offenen meer bauten
seitdem gehören sie zu den pionieren der
offshore-windkraft
gerade auch in der aktuellen situation
ist dass der weg den man einschlagen
muss der ausbau ist richtig und wichtig
vor allem ist es vorteilhaft die anlagen
auf dem meer zu bauen an land stören sie
ja
also ich bin für grüne energie ich finde
es sehr gut dass jetzt etwas passiert
und der ausbau voran kommt da draußen
nun plant das land den nächsten schritt
eine künstliche energie in mitten in der
90 die den strom der zahlreichen
windturbinen bündelt und vertreibt es
ist das größte bauprojekt der dänischen
geschichte für umgerechnet mehr als 28
milliarden euro
mit zehn gigawatt was der zukunftsplan
für diese insel ist wird dort genug
energie für zehn millionen haushalte
erzeugt und es gibt nur sechs millionen
menschen in dänemark also wollen wir
natürlich auch zur entwicklung einer
grünen strategie für ganz europa
der hafen von esbjerg von hier aus
stechen die schiffe mit den bauteilen zu
den plattformen und windparks wenn sie
demnächst wohl auch für die energie
dänemark setzt auf erneuerbare
energiequellen schon jetzt wird die
hälfte des strombedarfs mit windkraft
gedeckt zum vergleich in deutschland
sind es 27 in der eu 15 prozent
die nordsee bietet das größte potenzial
überhaupt in europa und eines der
stärksten weltweit
die windbedingungen sind optimal flächen
sind vorhanden und die eu hat klare
ziele 300 gigawatt bis zum jahr 2050
das ist das potenzial das es jetzt zu
heben gilt
eine verzwanzigfachen der offshore
kapazitäten also und so werden in diesem
jahr vor den europäischen küsten so
viele anlagen in betrieb genommen wie
nie zuvor vorbild denn
ja und bevor heute nachmittag mit
kanzler choice zusammen nach dänemark
reist zu dem gipfeltreffen ist robert
habeck vizekanzler und
bundeswirtschaftsminister bei uns im
studio guten morgen guten morgen wir
gerade gehört die eu plant eine
verzwanzigfachen der offshore
kapazitäten bis 2050 wie stark engagiert
sich deutschland sehr stark und sie über
den nationalen pläne sind ja dass hier
bis 2030 post
die kapazitäten auf 35 gigawatt ein
gigawatt kann man sich ungefähr merken
ist quasi ein atomkraftwerk oder ein
kohlekraftwerk ein großes kohlekraftwerk
erhöhen wollen dann auf 70 gehen das
muss man sich mal vorstellen was das für
eine menge ist dann aber das besondere
ist eigentlich dass da jetzt die ersten
europäischen kraftwerke entstehen also
die projekte sollen gemeinsam entwickelt
gemeinsam finanziert und der strom
gemeinsam verteilt werden das ist
eigentlich das besondere auch an diesem
gipfel heute dass nicht mehr jedes land
seine eigenen kram macht sondern dass
man das wirklich kooperiert kooperativ
angeht da war ja nicht nur um die
gigantischen offshore anlagen an sich
geht oder natürlich dann auch um die
nachgelagerte infrastruktur muss eben
auch hapert wie sieht's da moment in
deutschland auskommen wir endlich voran
absolut wenn man die windparks auf see
hat dann muss ja irgendwie der strom-
oder die energie zumindestens an land
gebracht werden und wenn jetzt jedes
land seine eigenen kabel durchzieht auch
durchs wattenmeer das sind ja hoch
sensible gebiete dann hat man den
kabelsalat das macht viel mehr sinn zu
schauen welche länder planen was wir
beteiligt man sich daran wie verbindet
man das miteinander man hat man dann
würde das aber jetzt ein backbone 1 1
ein rückgrat der netz infrastruktur
geschaffen und an land werden dann die
energie wird sich dann weiter verteilt
durch die verteilnetze oder verwandelt
in wasserstoff das sind der große mengen
die angelandet werden da wird also das
was wir im moment alles planen
produziert auf europäischem boden
nämlich erneuerbare energie in
gebundener gas form also wasserstoff
egal wie sehr sie da jetzt aufs tempo
drücken das wird natürlich trotzdem noch
eine weile dauern was ein bisschen
kurzfristiger jetzt wirken kann ist das
energiesparen wofür sie gestern auch
nochmal geworben haben ist das
tatsächlich eine notwendigkeit weil die
energie sonst in den nächsten monaten
nicht reicht das kommt vor allem wie
sich die lage entwickelt aber es ist
jeden fall hilfreich egal wie sich die
lage entwickelt wir reden immer alle
politisch ich auch dauernd über die
errichtung von neuen windparks und lng
terminals und kabel und dann gibt es
proteste dagegen und das ist ja auch
klar dass da das sind die bild stärkeren
geschichten aber die alles eigentliche
geheimen ist auch für den geldbeutel wie
für die unabhängigkeit von putins
energie ist keine oder weniger energie
zu verbrauchen und da gibt es große
maßnahmen gesetzliche maßnahmen wir
bauen unsere gebäude anlass dafür sind
die gesetze in vorbereitung wie beiträge
wie jedes unternehmen und jeder alleine
machen kann und wir haben gestern einen
arbeitsplan klimaschutz oder
energieeffizienz vorgelegt wo man
nochmal in verschiedenen maßen haben
sich anschauen kann gucken kann wo wir
stehen und wir werden auch eine große
oder sind schon dabei eine große
beratungs kampagne aufzulegen so dass
wenn man sagt mir was kann ich denn noch
tun dann gibt es jemanden anderen ab für
andere seite des telefons und sagen der
sagt haben ein bisschen was geht bei
jedem eben gerade noch eine weitere
maßnahme angesprochen den ausbau von
energie also flüssig erdgas morgen also
am donnerstag zweite und dritte lesung
dann schon im bundestag
naturschutzverbände wollen klagen weil
zum beispiel die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung zum teil
zumindest ausgesetzt werden das heißt an
so einer stelle ist es tatsächlich auch
ihre aufgabe sehr viele kompromisse
einzugehen obwohl sie zu lasten der
ökologie gehen also da hat sich jetzt
mal ein bisschen was verändert insofern
haben die umweltverbände
die haben ja einen punkt die
umweltstandards werden ein stück weit
zurückgenommen nicht materiell aber im
verfahren also man kann schon anfangen
zu bauen und dann wird man danach
geguckt welche vorgaben dann von der
infrastruktur eingehalten werden müssen
also welche abgaswerte welche
emissionsschutz werte welche lärmwerte
und so weiter für die festen anlagen
also die terminals haben wir jetzt
wieder für die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung das
reguläre verfahren gewählt alle anderen
sachen diese schiffe die wir anwenden da
bleibt es bei der aussetzung der
genehmigung bevor man rahmen und bauen
kann ich halte das für absolut notwendig
ich glaube dass die umweltverbände haben
natürlich recht wir müssen die umwelt
schützen aber wir sind in einer
absoluten krisensituationen ist jetzt
meine aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass im
fall der fälle und das hieße putin dreht
uns den gashahn ab dass wir nicht
komplett nackt durch den winter laufen
müssen und das hat absoluten vorrang und
ja bitte ich bei aller liebe für natur
und umweltschutz und die
naturschutzverbände um verständnis in
der sache ändert sich ja auch gar nichts
nur die verfahren werden nachgelagert
oder verkürzt betrieben so können wir
halt nur so haben wir eine chance zum
winter eine gewisse widerständigkeit zu
haben und ich hoffe dass die
umweltverbände nicht nur auf die aspekte
schauen sondern auf die wirklich
drängenden nationale notlage die
passieren würde wenn wir kein gas aus
russland bekommen würden also absolute
krisensituationen sagen sie umso
wichtiger ist da natürlich auch eine in
sich stimmige und gut funktionierende
bundesregierung jetzt gucken wir auf die
letzten beiden landtagswahlen und dass
es sozusagen jetzt mal ein paar wochen
her die grünen das wird sich natürlich
freuen haben jetzt am sonntag ihren
stimmenanteil verdreifacht die fdp ist
abgeschmiert die sehr belastet dass die
ampel regierung naja wir sehen auch
nachrichten und lesen zeitung und sind
teilweise in den wahlkämpfen der
involvierten christian lindner als
parteivorsitzender also dass wir jetzt
gelogen wenn man sagt das interessiert
niemanden
aber ich glaube alle wissen dass hier im
moment nicht für parteien politik machen
sondern für das land für deutschland für
die menschen und deswegen soll man sich
damit jetzt nicht zu lange aufhalten ich
würde sagen einmal schütteln auch wenn
es nicht so gut gelaufen ist bzw nicht
abheben oder irgendwie dumme sprüche
machen wir gelaufen ist wie jetzt bei
uns das nächste mal kann es auch wieder
anders kommen und konzentriert an der
sache arbeiten
bundeswirtschaftsminister und
vizekanzler robert habeck war das bevor
sie dann nachher weiter nach dänemark
reisen finanzieren besuchen das
interview morgen